yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I'm
on one time yeah it's ten ten in the
evening wasn't sure thing going to make
it but I'm right on time you hello to
all of you watching hello to or that's
my self no to triple check ur to roche
to cut some men cutter montello edith
and to Hobgoblin a couple of people in
the chat yeah join twitch and chat
that's always good young chatting with
me exchanging thoughts about the games
or asking questions oh it's good to
participate so make sure to huge them
the twitch functionality with the chat
so we're going to play a couple of games
and I haven't played a blitz game today
so I'm happy to play a couple of games
and see what happens see if i can get a
five minute game going yeah also good
evening to core st and to that shin
skull gotcha disco I'm sorry ok going to
play mock y FM mock why ok so we get
some kind of old Indian I guess can
transpose to a king's indian still but
ok it doesn't happen i usually play with
this Bishop b3 set up then go for d5 I
think that white always should have a
somewhat more pleasant game here aha
it's going back to f8 interesting do I
play before I don't know I can also play
this typical strengthening moves yellow
also the two books are nice case like
six air and robo and blackbird yeah some
people in the chest and to sign wells
yeah or people in the chat
riding here also hello to igniting ideas
ok so this game i played f3 and g3 this
is to limit the options of black here on
the King side is going h5 hmm that's
that's an interesting move always a
little bit a little bit hard to evaluate
this kind of move can be weakening it
can also be helpful for black I'm
playing h4 to stop that so there is
maybe try to play a sacrifice on each
floor i'm going to cover the edge for
porn yeah and someone says good time of
data you have only my chest friends yeah
this is a yeah yeah most typical way to
start of a broadcast or show so i'm not
going to copy that I'm sticking with
welcome to this video and welcome to
this broadcast it's somehow I got the
got to be the usual way I'm starting
starting something I'm doing him okay so
what about this here I wonder if he can
maybe take on age 40 and play Knight f
for this kind of thing but it lacks a
check on the G file I don't think that
this is going to work so maybe you'll
see one going on the c4c file you hello
to Martin Riggs so I'm still want to
play in three before someone suggest i
should play a game of losers or giveaway
chest i have to be perfectly honest I
don't even know the rules of those
someone wants me to play Kings gambit
yeah well I can try e4 at least somewhat
later okay i wonder if i should have
just taken c5 you see going for f5 when
i can i can still cover at five a little
bit more make it more difficult for him
to play okay now is coming with the
possible f5 but I'm not sure that this
is really helping that much I want to be
ready to respond with f4 and I have much
more space okay i think i'm going to
take now open up the be foul and I
wonder if f4 is an idea here I think I
should wait until he gets to play a 5
himself yes I was surprised that her own
young got the wild card from with the
tournament being in Russia I mean it's
um it's a it's a it's a it's a good good
news in my book to have Aronian playing
but it's still surprising okay I'm
trying to play night to be 6 and trade
something o Queen to age 3 this is a
move that I did not anticipate oh that's
that's really bad actually now I didn't
see that coming at all not quite sure
how bad it is but it wasn't something
that I had planned we're at five
no is trying for some under stuff for
some f5 business I don't know yeah
anyway I want to go Bishop f1 and kick
the Queen out this is such such an
annoying piece there on age three ah
come on why is why other people spamming
the chat and I cannot bend because i'm
not i'm not the the admin
yeah we need a lot definitely need a lot
so I'm going with 94 here and he goes to
D Phi and so I have to take this there's
no choice then but now I have night
should be six and after he captures
rugby 6 d 6 is worse it's difficult to
cover I don't have more rights I asked
for them but they're usually I know
they're usually quite busy with with
some other stuff so it didn't do that
yet okay rook on b6 as a tech I should
cover it no that was my telephone
and may have I need to call call the
cops so to say so okay you went Knight
to d7 did I blunder the game due to that
stuff or not rook these six I can still
do that d3 i've got Queen f2 okay so
let's just take it and now can I take on
g6 it's that winning or not probably not
so we'll just play normal moves
threatening 95 now I think 95 is going
to play Bishop f5 I can just go over
here and go 96 next
so instead some way I can use a discover
check I can I can do that I know I can
take with the real car and I with the
night I'm sorry yeah well 96 is good
though 96 seems good let's check a five
years no reason no defense there okay
pawn takes is not working I can take
with the Queen that could be an idea
it's probably easier than the other
continuations he resigned yeah so I got
the I gotta win it so I hope I can
concentrate on the game now a little bit
better so that we have mod cleaning up
the chat okay a new game against
conceited yeah so Kramnik didn't get the
wild card yeah I think maybe that one
rationale was that Russia already has to
play as in them you know they have fun
Wow someone is really playing that line
um what what what do they have they have
kayaking and and some other guy and
Swilley Swilley already in okay I'm a
bit surprised that this guy a played
this is super super sharp line is that
good threatening nights is seven now
it's hard to believe
King f7 said the idea maybe King f7
could be a move Wow maybe someone says
Villa doesn't really belong oh he does
it definitely does yeah he's the seventh
time Russian champion yeah so he does
belong into that field and he qualified
yeah this is a typical thing that I
don't understand people say and this
isn't that player should should should
be in there so they qualified if you
qualify if you qualified you have all
the rights to be there so what now came
to f7 hmm a nexus 7 doesn't lead to
anything I'm kind of boxed in that's the
problem here that seems to be good for
black of this position 97 it's never
really going to work maybe NAT c7 and
queen bee three or so let's try that yes
Villa 177 russian championships yeah I
tried this year attacking d5 and
possibly having the idea play 96 I don't
like this position so much yeah giri is
also in there we have a couple of
younger players now and interesting
players caruana for the first time and I
camera for the first time very good very
good field looking forward to that event
very much
so night i was thinking night 86 takes
bishop be a damn it looks kind of kind
of wrong
yeah 9 a-6 looks looks weird but
yeah not sure what blackwell we do here
okay probably yeah there will be the
London chess classics something to look
forward to so I was thinking nights if
five I don't want to draw so 95 so I'm
going back I think that question with
the seven russian championships and
qualified is a joke right yeah I mean of
course if you qualify you you should you
you are there and with other and you
definitely have deserved and you
definitely deserve to be there so yeah
that's a very strange position very
strange position night f-for maybe s got
Knight a5 I would like to develop but to
start not so it doesn't seem to be so
easy mm-hmm cannot move my bishop from
everyone
yeah maybe here and then try g3 ya aku
baru ben stein is participating in the
chat and he says back in this day they
need sponded sponsors then they need to
find a sponsor for the for the match
that's a good good question by w course
and what do you think is the best way to
keep up your chest close as best as
possible the limited time and you can't
play our studies often as you'd like
yeah okay still you should try to try to
play as much as you can yeah somehow
managed yeah it's still impossible to
get get some games get some games in and
I think probably tactics are doing lots
of tactics and cell phone okay while
stating that it looks like I'm in a
critical position here I think I have to
take and he threatens to take on d3 and
check me on c1 this is quite an
annoyance hmm and I don't have good
squares should g2 Teague's cheeks or
queen see what I've got kingi to this is
so kind of playable yeah I think tactics
would be important if you cannot play
that much keep your tactics in shape
it's definitely helpful and and try to
play at least a little bit I mean even
online you can play quite a bit of games
in various time controls yeah this is an
interesting position if i get to castle
I'm just fine but am I able to yeah you
have to move the King unfortunately but
rookie one is not a bad move to get in
it's a bit of a strange position but I
don't think it is that bad okay 94
is that just fancy stuff that doesn't
lead to anywhere and my night doesn't
have many squares ok I'd I'm attacking
the the bishop 1c5 so maybe but it
mostly is looking fancy ok I'd c5 midst
it's not so great maybe I should have
played this differently ok it's not
attacking the knight still age 3 maybe I
takes Bishop takes is called 93 check ok
that could be an issue not much that I
can do
a 5-1 he wants to go a for it seems okay
I can take the pawn now on g4 that's not
bad ok g4 Hanks but I can also attack
his pawns down 26 maybe maybe queen is
60 should be a five Bishop yeah i mean
the ship d tool let's do this first get
rid of the double porn so what is this a
3 coming we've got equal material here
guys he's getting this this is bad ah
this is bad not quite sure what happened
in this game I think I wasn't in decent
shape again but I screwed it up okay
just nights before we win did you also
will win but now he's taking time mmm f8
I've got f8 queen coming I was he doing
to see doing against that nothing I
guess chick chick hmm wow I have no idea
i hope i'm not getting checkmated myself
now I list I lost some time ah I'm just
too I'm practical I could have just one
on time of course that's a question by
igniting ideas about the McKagan of
variation of the Kings Indian the h3 the
age three lines and the question is the
difference between putting the bishop on
g5 on Nov 3 that's a that's an
explanation the bishop goes to g5 when
there is some use of that fianchetto of
that pin yeah if you want to pin in all
other cases the bishop is better only
three so there are some cases where the
pin is useful to provoke age six but if
black for example has already gotten to
your age with the queen or something and
there is no pin then you go to you three
but you really have to look at that line
by line question wife Lenore about the
modern be known you with f1 Bishop b5
check what the theoretical verdict is um
yeah fyb should be five check yeah I
hate to be honest I
fact that black is okay simply because
it's not that Plato often by white
nowadays but I cannot really give you a
concrete line I suppose it's something
with bishop age with Queen edge form and
back to e7 but i'm not entirely sure I
think you probably should look should
look at the book by um this Bulgarian
grandest master my aunt Petrov ah this
bloody line yeah it is no good but it is
also easy to forget so 95 it's not f5 a
move then and then you go t5 I can I
always forget this I always forget this
and I said this isn't particularly great
for white but it's easy to forget ok
taking a fire from me not ok so he wants
to go with Bishop a three hmm so how is
this played f6 I think I think of six
the banker with Quincy to was
interesting for white out of that John
Watson book um I looked at this some
time ago and I felt it was ok ok so he
it wants to play on that that pin now I
really hate it if they play in line
that's essentially not doing anything
but you have to know what to do and you
forget the way to play it now nitey for
is a threat
that's a pure trick line but I think it
tricked me already hmm hard to say
cannot go Queen f6 i mean i can but
Bishop takes d5 is covering the f porn
this is the problem
I don't I don't know what to do maybe
this 94 Queen f7 hmm 994 Queen f7 you
can take with the bishop on c5 this is
completely ridiculous it doesn't work it
doesn't work at all ah what a bad game
wow I really hate this game let us that
sir this deadline is really rubbish for
white but I forgot how it is played and
it's tricky how is that played 94 is
that wrong no what cannot be wrong
there's this I think this is this is a
line night a for Queen g4 I think this
is right or do I have to take on f4 f5
here or something like that this is just
trickery it is not good not good at all
do I have to take on a five now my okay
let's go to the next next game rook to x
f2 also didn't work ah now ki will avail
you have to refresh all of those those
weird sidelines you should have five
Bishop g5 Bishop c2 maybe or something
this is the air I have the Apple watch
people ask about the watch I don't get a
game though
yes I got the ball or gunwoo Lopez book
I also do a review on it but in order to
do that I have to really look at the
book in some detail first it looks
excellent of course but this is
something that is expected that's the
question do I agree with chargeman that
chess is ninety-nine percent tactics 99
is a lot Buddhist and it is quite a bit
yeah 99 is a bit much maybe like eighty
to ninety percent proper calculation is
super important and so the grown
pre-attack as a main repertoire to the
sicilian no i wouldn't recommend that
doesn't it doesn't feel doesn't feel
feel like a right choice Black has many
promising ways against it there's no
stock fish chef for the Apple watch I
think yeah I yesterday I had the first
league game since I got that watch and I
actually took it off before the game I
think it's better to avoid any kind of
irritation okay I'm trying to regroup
the night here to d3 okay he goes with
you five so what about this now 93 now
we will take platform shouldn't blunder
every piece I wonder if it is an idea to
take on a form my game yesterday I play
total rubbish and lost it was really
really awful
I probably won't make a video on that it
was just just just a bad game it isn't
even very instructive it was just a very
very bad play on my part so we've got
this end game and it's kind of
interesting so if I go 95 that was the
idea if not he goes Knight d4 so okay
you might be 94 anyway no I'm attacking
c7 that's not going to work it was a
Belgium League I cut down on my league
games to do more chance teaching or
let's say I do so much chest teaching
during the week that I'm happy to have
week weekends off like chess free sunday
or something would be good but I wanted
to play a match to play a game to get ya
warmed up a little bit for my german
german league match next week and it
didn't work I mean I just played such
utter rubbish I played against an
international master with about my
rating maybe it's got a couple of points
and a couple of points less than I have
but not much about the same level yeah
this I was thinking about it shouldn't
be the end of the world though
quite a strange position
the hyperaccelerated dragon is an
interesting opening against you for the
problem is that you still get the more
oxy bind which simply does not equal
eyes ever I mean okay the more oxy is
also not like losing so if you like them
if you like the resulting position
somehow then by all means go for it
that's the only issue with it there's
nothing nothing wrong with the opening
otherwise it's just a peroxy bind yeah
some more yard bird is not playing can i
play nitey a bishop 64 hear or see takes
I let's go see takes I mean this should
be really okay for Mia some kind of
Jewish and gamer what my score against
Yardbird yeah I'm like minus 5 or minus
6i think yeah we have like fifty
something games going in our history
okay he went night to be five didn't
didn't expect that move but well anyway
he cannot do that much but i also don't
have any great ideas may be here i don't
know yeah someone mentions the match
against Finn against Finn's I'm sorry
John perform you yeah and it was
entertaining right i hope you guide guys
enjoyed it i also felt it was good fun
of course i would have liked to win it
but it was close I mean the longer time
control games the regular blitz we go on
on equal equal terms and only in the
bullet he managed to get a couple on
a couple of points yeah we definitely
play again so drop drawing the
retreating this try to get the d5 pawn
okay now he has to go back now maybe
over there seagoing night at five maybe
he still cannot take on d5 night at 5i
think I go III if he takes on d5 twice
I'll take on c7 that cannot be that bad
for white I will look daddy
really not playing well so far not at
all so this one no I get the skid sis
gets all this activity now maybe I
should try to go to eat too quickly here
yeah the games against all I guess they
often have memorable quotes there will
be something nice coming up I can
promise you that the screw you I had
this screw you buddy once and something
yeah we get to something it's something
comparable soon yeah I want to keep the
pawn the deep on and maybe rookie aid or
something so going there I wonder can
you regroup can try to go up here maybe
that doesn't help at all but I don't see
him doing that much he can go there hmm
can go rook f8 or create
let's prevent this for the time being
this should be true coming or something
I wonder there's some kind of meeting
ideas here I don't see how that would
work though rookie 7 I can try this I
can try this move that is actually quite
good yeah he resigns atb window never
lose on time yeah I had diner dad and I
had them I had the pact with the devil
comment yeah ok nostril yeah playing
nostril who is that exactly let's check
no name he's got no name yeah the Trump
offski what to do against the Trump off
skype I usually play 94 and then g5 the
line that Boris I've Rock recommended in
his books dealing with deform the
default deviations book I think it's a
very good very good line d4f I've Bishop
g5 is a good line against the Dutch yes
can be recommended this is a very dull
line this guy is not doing much in terms
of aggressiveness okay Wow
yeah this is a fairly well-known kind of
structure where simply nothing is
happening black is equalized even though
white can can claim that with the bishop
he's got a little bit more in terms of
ideas it's difficult though someone
asked what about showing some lesson of
mine to a student some lesson that I do
with a student to show to the YouTube
community to see how I work an
interesting idea never thought about
that okay mean I've done a couple of
instructive videos that certainly gives
you an idea how I convey em says I d
a--'s so it's nothing that I have not
done in a way but showing a real lesson
i think is a bit difficult as the
student yeah he gets a yeah one-on-one
let's say experience and sharing that
with all of YouTube um not really the
idea of it yeah the avaril books as the
double GM repertoire books are very very
deep and tough to memorize and I also
don't recommend them to too many people
only two very young yeah only rather
high rated players
yeah I didn't like to play be five but I
wasn't quite sure how to how to avoid it
was a bit yeah it's not the most
convenient position why it has a slide
pool it shouldn't be fatal or anything
but it's it's they cannot do much yeah
more three minute madness that's an
interesting request hmm yeah I haven't
done those for a while but they are
usually fun to do maybe I should do more
of that
so with the knight on d5 is very
difficult for him to get anything going
but the same is supplying for me I also
cannot do much maybe I put the Queen on
26 I have no particular plans for a
Christmas video we have to be cautious
here h5 is hanging and possibly
sacrifice on e6 it's not ideal king of
eight doesn't look like a great move but
I don't think he has a sacrifice i will
definitely do Christmas stuff but not
quite sure what certainly some streams
Christmas time you won't have a little
bit more time yeah viewer game would be
good to do ya have a couple of things
currently on my plate that I bit
difficult to make them yeah to produce
much of contents it's somewhat between
private stuff and work so nothing bad
it's just that I'm kind of busy so let's
see how can I this is not really working
right I cannot believe it but how
exactly do I playing maybe bring the
king of
I don't think this can objectively be
working what he did but it's it's it's
definitely dangerous route cakes is six
can be an idea in some position maybe
even here no not here what is this try
to sacrifice on e6 maybe I want to do
this and then go to the aid takes things
that's also not going to work I don't
get it what is he doing here I don't get
this the sacrifice if I get to play King
d8 it's just over in terms of a direct
attack
even King be six is an idea even though
that looks kind of kind of weird so what
about this is attacking e6 and the
taking of the rook but I can just go
back here right whereas the threat I
don't see a threat and I'm threatening
night f4 now probably rookie 5 and some
kind of trying to irritate me there f6
even though rookie fan f6 also not going
to work okay night f four years possible
but you can move the rock moving the
rock and then I g6 could be interesting
okay cannot take my idea was to just
drop the night back and trying to trap
is Queen threatening rook h8 now
trapping the Queen okay look age 8 and
then it's the Queen but it will take
with the pawn take on edge 7 pawn takes
and promotes yeah so it's going for some
trickery here as he should being in a
completely lost position so f five maybe
I hope that this works I would really
feel it's completely unfair if not a
damn i'm always in i'm always able to
screw things up with some tactical
blunder
okay so this one
so how do I win this position i think
i'm going to activate the Queen Queen to
have three those kind of ideas and try
to win the pawn that also is immensely
helpful getting that pawn so can I bring
the king right into the action that
should help with checkmating and maybe
I'm checkmating myself that's also not
great okay I was bad bad idea now I
think he's he may be asked to draw with
the apron and I've down on time
offering in the draw
it didn't want to draw okay okay I
cannot do more than offer it and okay so
let's see what happens here not
especially proud of that when I should
have one like on position but I didn't
see that rookie three coming it was kind
of annoying so what do we have next what
is less work to learn against money for
the Sicilian on 1e5 hmm i think that
depends a little bit on the sicilian
line if you play a Sicilian sideline may
be Sicilian is even less work but it's
both own it's both them and not so easy
to learn I mean it's a myth that if I
this kind of are all those Gamble's and
so on those gamblers are usually not
very good the other side lines you have
to look at them look it up and learn it
but it's it's it's doable in the
Sicilian it depends a little bit on the
line if you play a Sicilian main line
and go for sharp stuff and Sicilian will
be tougher because the the price of a
mistake is higher yeah if you played so
your night off and play the poisoned
pawn and you cannot remember stuff you
just lose the game and this is not going
to happen in some hello briar road opus
okay playing bua bua berber this is some
Grandmaster Vladimir Markin surprised
that he's playing this kind of line
didn't know what he plays okay yeah an
opening like the caro-kann is easier to
learn that is absolutely out of the
question so surprisingly this guy is
playing a inferior version here of them
of the
of the maroc see point here white is
just better a bit surprised that is
playing an opening like that okay let's
see what happens b3 i can go 95
immediately why do top games not play
the French defense [ __ ] hmm why dont
they play it more I think the French
defense is somewhat ism is a pretty it's
it's of course okay but it's difficult
to play as a as a surprise weapon or so
because you really really really have to
know stuff very precisely yeah and I
think people at the highest level they
don't want to invest the time to to make
the French they are their main weapon
they are rather interested in complete
equality which is why they often go for
some lines in them in the Rue La Paz
like them like the like the balloon
defense or they go for complications
right of the bed and this means they go
for a Sicilian they usually have those
two options and they are not looking at
the French defense that much forum
balancing but there is no objective
reason to do so i think i took with the
sea porn yeah this is often a difficult
decision in the in the maroc see bind
both recaptures do promise white little
something and it's sometimes difficult
to say what is better in this case i
took with the sea pony so i can take now
on b5 but it shouldn't be any good maybe
just win a little bit more space IAM
yeah the bull in defense is not
something that is very popular with the
chest community I understand it is quite
often a bit annoying to have that to
have that end game all of the time I
understand young people really want to
see a little bit more variety I think
that the Berlin end game actually isn't
that uninteresting it just a bit dull to
have it to have it that often yeah it's
just happening that often and there are
some lines in the Berlin and I don't
even mean the end gamer there's some
other lines like rookie one that has
simply exceptionally dull yeah I mean
this is so doll that you I mean if you
would play that against someone like two
or three hundred points higher you would
easily think that you would draw and
this is really really boring ok so here
I'll get you five and but probably yeah
I want to keep a little bit material on
the board not sure that it does help to
make things more interesting but I try
ok so he wants to trade like that yeah
I've couldn't really do much against
this let's go e6 the simplest opening to
play against d4 yeah probably some
Queens gambit I would recommend the
Queens gambit accepted personally not
saying that it is super simple but it is
certainly doable so what about this I'm
getting in Bishop's eh here I wonder can
I do something here I've got his King
out of the picture
if I go around hmm ice covering like
that okay i need i need to do it with
the bishop on the threesome oh maybe I
don't get it anymore okay now I can do
this probably I cannot win anymore
Bishop d3 able take let's go here
there's no way to win unfortunately
maybe I could do something Simon
Williams recommends to play night before
in the French wow that's a weird idea ya
think it's just bad 94 in the classical
variation that's just a bad idea okay
i'm going to offer draw him and here he
offered the draw earlier but I couldn't
I still see it unfortunately
the Queens gambit accepted yeah because
you get it quite often yeah you get it
often and you can concentrate on a
couple of lines blankets often selecting
the lines this is why the Queens gambit
accepted accepted is some I think
relatively simple to learn there's a
question you're going clop from a coach
of Brewster Dortmund and football soccer
refers to his gig and pressing football
as heavy metal football what kind of
music would you call your Chester I have
no idea I don't know if I have a
particular Chester and there's a
question how much do you think playing
blitzes regularly as you do in spending
time with videos and coaching has hurt
your game um yeah the thing is um I
think it it's not particularly helpful I
mean I do a lot of chess with with the
teaching and the videos and so on um um
it doesn't help your game that's pretty
much clear how much does it hurt hmm
difficult to say I really it's really
are the same um the thing is that
nowadays I actually enjoy enjoy the
teaching and and producing of content um
more and more than actually playing
longer games I really don't mind blitz
and rapid chess but the tournament the
long time control tournament games
sometimes I'm a little bit long for my
taste I mean spending a whole day for
the game we recently had an article by
Greg shot him about his ideas of
reforming yeah the classical town
control too quick a time control and i
have to say that in some some some days
i do agree
that I really like to play a little bit
more quicker tile control yeah with them
I don't think that blitz is something
that blitz is something that hurts my
game I don't play in lots of glitz
actually this is like three games a day
on average you know this is not so much
and it's not really a lot so which
specific structure do I have in mind
with the Queens gambit accepted and yeah
there are ideas with Bishop g4 that are
interesting or quick a six ideas there
are a couple of um interesting lines
that black and go for black gets to
choose the variation I know white white
initially selects like III neither three
or four but against all of those moves
Black has a choice and in many cases I
think blacks possible or choices are
pretty good and sometimes in most cases
lead to interesting play so yeah so I'm
putting some pressure on the C file if
he goes ruchi aight i have no idea form
so i'm looking forward to that and that
being played probably not going to
happen oh it is going to happen okay and
no rook g8 okay this is also not not not
bad i have 95 coming and possibly 96 but
it wasn't intended it wasn't intended at
all and okay so II went here okay I can
go here and rook to Queen d5 I can take
c7 I have that counter idea no problem
whatsoever
so now I can still play 95 maybe do that
it's not ideal but what can you do
a key bar says he has to go what Cuba
Rubenstein was participating in the chat
yeah they're telling me he has to go
yeah it's difficult yeah I mean being
dead for almost 50 years it's difficult
to just yeah get up 44 chest stream so i
wanted to check on b7 but now i see
that's not even possible or is it if i
take there is he tripping my night I
think years say hi to last scan kappa
blanca yeah a chess tournament in heaven
would be kind of kind of interesting who
would win against eform in the Queens
gambit accepted there is the move knight
c6 which is very interesting this is
something that I am looked a little bit
which I check myself and now it's
recommended in those in those books in
this book by by Del chef
yeah I'm just playing some regular as
some routine improving moves without any
specific idea have to admit maybe I
should have played something to do one
now that would have would have helped I
guess yeah it would have helped not good
the strongest European countries and
chairs to Russia
now paying too much attention to the
chat today have to admit always looking
to the shed window probably would help
but I can get the shed somewhere here
okay so what now um yeah g5 don't know
don't like my position of course some
g-form SMG five or here maybe f1
actually maybe going for f-4s
interesting yeah that's actually
interesting idea let's try for that the
strongest chest nation relative to pop
to population size is probably iceland
iceland has tons of GMS they don't have
a super super duper top GM but lots of
let's say normal regular GM's so g5 or
not Luke g1 is coming hmm don't like the
look of that
ok I can go to f3 yeah you can check me
again maybe go to h2 then let's not easy
here night h3 is going book before not
good that's a pretty bad position yeah
akiba is still hanging around in the
chatter even though we asked to play in
a tournament together to tomorrow
against Fisher that's no good ok so is
trying to checkmate me isn't that evil
evil intention see by piness Oh mmm look
everyone King to e2 it doesn't look good
huh well I hate my position I absolutely
hate my position here Luke c2e2 rook f1
is a direct mate Wow
I don't even see a move that I can play
it's amazingly bad
this is I'm just blundering the night
but and didn't have a move I didn't have
a move it was just lost I think very bad
position Wow very bad position okay one
more game
I don't think that chest can be
destroyed completely by computers in
deeper theory there will always be other
ideas and the thing is well if the
theory is expanding more I mean they
just want they just TV deviate early you
see it with Carlton's games he's playing
without any deep opening theory
sometimes and he's doing quite Oh game
so I don't think that currently we are
in a state where with theory is
important but Carlin shows that you can
do it without lots of theory ok so I've
gone for some kind of double fianchetto
here kind of weird but hmm Queen F or
maybe Mac think i have Knight f6 just
about so we get some kind of Sicilian
where don't have any development if I
this on the cards be 55 it looks damn
dangerous
yeah I play a key x el y am playing
Winston huh okay but I go be4 Bishop e7
takes on c3 this kind of thing that
looks really bad
Queen B 6 you take b7 and play five this
is going to be a huge problem e5 be four
tix f-16 that's not working
pretty bad position I love the kind of
questions with sometimes get if I saw
what hair implants of course not I think
it's pretty okay like like the way it is
now influence i need brain implants yeah
this position is just lost oh my god
yeah that's probably once you get
playing this kind of rubbish openings
play mukti ate here Queen somewhere now
let's do this
I think that has been worse actually not
that I like my position but it was worse
before Quincy five I guess no aha why is
he returning material I don't quite get
it okay I'm taking here Roxy's 6i wants
to take g6 I look to the south he wants
to take okay so let's go see 5 mm and I
was thinking I have something on the
back rang of course I don't ah ah been a
long day huh I really played total
rubbish tonight how did I keep my rating
I feel like I'm lost our games probably
didn't but it feels like it
you
thank you wow that was a bad game yeah I
need to update my profile picture I'm
pretty Hume you're pretty right yeah
there's a book to explain the knight c6
lines in the e4 Queens gambit accepted
this is the book by Del chef that I that
I mentioned I hope you enjoyed the
stream I don't know I was kind of not
really focused but I hope you still
enjoyed enjoyed some of the games some
of the chat it was good fun for me even
though I played some what some would we
are chess okay thanks guys i'm back next
week